[Music]
the work of isaac asimov is finally
being adapted in a way that it never has
before
and no i don't mean the irobot sequel
with will smith returning as the lead
actor
please be a rumor apple tv is adapting
his most famous work
the foundation series into a tv show the
original foundation trilogy presented
what is considered to be
pretty much the first ever detailed
depiction of a galactic
empire to find out more about asimov's
work check out the foundation playlist
in the description for this video
however we'll be focusing on one
specific world
in asimov's vast empire and how that
world contributed to the fall of the
galactic empire
as a whole
[Music]
[Music]
asimov is to science fiction what j.r.r
tolkien is to fantasy
as i said azimov's foundation series is
his most famous work
but the seven books in the foundation
series contain only a small fraction of
the story of asimov's universe
the empire series includes three books
and one short story
and asimov's robot series consists of
six books and 37 short stories
azimov's science fiction universe is
undoubtedly one of the most
expansive ever created in this video
however we'll be focusing on one
specific world the planet trantor which
is the capital planet of the empire
and the center of the galaxy at the
start of the series trantor has been the
center of galactic government for
hundreds of generations
its grip on the empire was well
established but far
more fragile than anyone realized this
was due to several factors
before we get into some of the reasons
let's first discuss the culture
and the people that inhabit the planet
45 billion people lived on trantor
the world was divided into 800
administrative sectors
with approximately 50 million people
each each planet in the empire was
divided
in a similar way 12 of the sectors are
named over the course of the series
notably dahl one of the poorest sectors
on the world
and y located near the south pole where
lived the ancient
desian dynasty of emperors
not much is said of the culture of
trantor in the original books
it is not until asimov's book prelude to
foundation
that it is established the people of
trantor are mentioned
in prelude to foundation to be largely
diverse made up of easterners who
resemble the asians of old earth
westerners who resembled caucasians
and southerners who resembled black
people since the origins of mankind as a
whole
had been forgotten in the asimov
universe no one knows why they used
these terms
the diversity that would develop amongst
humankind once it spread out to form
galactic society
was something that asimov considered and
thought about at least somewhat
it is also mentioned that intermarriage
between different groups of people was
common
trantor has about 40 percent less
surface area
than earth the planet is encased
entirely in domes and towers
the only word that could be used to
properly describe the structure of
trantor
is an ecumenopolis the word ecumenopolis
was created by combining the greek word
acumen with the greek word polis this
literally translates to world
city the ecumenopolis of trantor
stretches deep underground
in layers upon layers most people of the
world rarely actually see the sun
and had special rooms which they entered
in order to simulate sunlight
this is the only way that its enormous
population could exist on one planet
trantor due to its importance as a
central world in the imperium
was the most densely populated and the
most industrially advanced planet
to ever exist twenty nearby agricultural
world supplied food to the planet
trantor
to suit the decadent expectations of the
trantorian people
fleets of tens of thousands of ships
delivered food to the world
far larger than any other fleets ever
constructed by the imperial navy
the carelessness of the most recent
rulers combined with the wastefulness of
trantor
and the ineffectiveness of the populace
to manage the imperial needs
was one of the key factors in the fall
of galactic society
the encyclopedia galactica states this
the population at its height was well in
excess of 40 billions
the enormous population was devoted
almost entirely to the administrative
necessities of the empire
and found themselves all too few for the
complications
of the task it is to be remembered that
the impossibility of proper
administration
of the galactic empire under the
uninspired leadership
of the later emperors was a considerable
factor in the fall
daily fleets of ships in the tens of
thousands brought the produce of 20
agricultural worlds
to the dinner tables of trantor its
dependence upon the outer world for food
and indeed for all necessities of life
made krantor increasingly vulnerable to
conquest by siege
in the last millennium of the empire the
monotonously numerous revolts
made emperor after emperor conscious of
this and the imperial policy became
little
more than the protection of trantor's
delicate jugular vein
at some point in history the world
trantor had actually been able to mostly
supply its own food
the book prelude to foundation mentions
full oceans
and farms and gardens of all kinds
surrounding the planet including
vast microorganism farms food was
important almost exclusively for lavish
indulgences
which was a tiny fraction of most
imports
it's true that we import considerable
quantities of food
but that's mostly luxury items and we
export considerable waste
carefully treated into inoffensiveness
as imported organic fertilizer
every bit as important to other worlds
as the food is to us
but that's only a small fraction of the
whole it is
yes in addition to fish and the sea
there are gardens and truck farms
everywhere
and fruit trees and poultry and rabbits
and vast microorganism farms
usually called yeast farms though the
yeast makes up a minority of the growths
and our wastes are mostly used right
here at home to maintain all that growth
the loss of food sustainability on
trantor of course led to their
dependency
on other worlds in order to survive
which is ultimately a key weakness
for the world and in turn the empire
itself
this coupled with the fact that the
world is simply
incapable of managing an empire of such
a large scale
was essential to the empire's fall
trantor being cut off from its supplies
would exacerbate what was already a
problem
considering things that occur later in
the books as well which i will not spoil
in this video
asimov seems to be making a statement
about the inherent problem with
centralized government
not only is trantor the center of
imperial administration
it is quite literally in the center of
the galaxy
though the singular rule of the planet
trantor worked well for many generations
the continued expansion of the human
universe became too much
to be maintained and orchestrated from a
singular place
decisions and whims made on trantor had
tremendous rippling impact on the whole
of galactic society
the lack of structural upkeep throughout
the empire
also led to the collapse of
infrastructure and an increase in crime
the empire could not be sustained
trantor
does not immediately collapse at the
fall of the galactic empire
but eventually it too falls
about 200 years after the imperial
collapse
trantor was attacked by multiple warring
kingdoms
each vying for power within the
fractured human universe
trantor is destroyed in the process and
eventually almost no one
other than the hamish people inhabited
the world
the hamish lived amongst the ruins of
trantor's destroyed cities
they were farmers who cultivated the
land and lived agrarian lifestyles
on a side note reading about the hamish
people that inhabit the ruins of trantor
reminds me a lot
of the various groups in larry nevin's
ring world series
in that series there are ring world
natives that inhabited the cities after
a devastating event which led to the
fall of the ring world
since we're on the subject to offer even
more clarity
let's talk about how the same idea is
depicted in another of my most favorite
science fiction series you guessed it
dune
and frank herbert's epic sci-fi series
which was also heavily influenced by the
work of asimov
the planet arrakis is essential to the
function of the empire
it is the only planet in the universe
where the substance known as the spice
melange is found
spice is necessary for space travel it
extends life and heightens awareness
many of the wealthiest throughout the
imperium are addicted
melange is key to the function of the
universe therefore
so is the planet arrakis if the
production of spice stopped
the universe would crumble into a dark
aegis arrakis eventually does become the
imperial center
as house atreides eventually governs the
empire from the world
the fate of the empire being tied to
iraq is means that decisions on the
world
would have the same enormous effect that
decisions made on the planet trantor in
asimov's universe had
the effect of paul atreides actions on
the planet dune
were magnified by the fact that the
events themselves
took place on arrakis dune and
foundation seem to essentially handle
this idea in the same way
both series seem to be making the same
argument criticizing centralized
governments being in charge of making
decisions
for the whole of humanity both series
seem to imply that humankind is better
served by decentralized governments
that operate by arbitration on a
case-by-case basis or at least
maybe i think it's time for some major
spoilers
for both series so if you don't want to
be spoiled
look away but if you don't care stay
here
i just said that both series seem to be
criticizing centralized governments
singular entities placed in charge of
the whole of humanity
are inherently problematic however
in both series the human universe is
maintained
and guided away from annihilation by a
non-human entity
in doom there is the god emperor late to
the second who joined with the sand
trout of the desert planet arrakis
transcending his humanity
and foundation there is daniel oliva
now you can check out the full video i
did on this character
here daniel is an ancient robot from
back when earth was still
inhabited throughout asimov's books he
shows up in various disguises carefully
pulling the threads of mankind
and a millennia-long plan to shape the
ultimate fate of mankind
if you are familiar with the god emperor
of dune then you can see how these two
characters are similar
both take the fate of mankind into their
own hands
and leads them into indefinite continued
existence
so maybe these theories are not saying
that a singular
entity leading humankind is necessarily
bad
just that it is impossible for one human
or even a centralized
group of humans and thus requires
a god or an ultra intelligence ai
or at least this is my interpretation
tell me what you think
in the comments below the planet trantor
appears and is mentioned in several
books throughout asimov's collected
universe
it is the first world that appears in
the first published foundation book
the idea of a world so industrialized so
dominated by human engineering that its
citizens rarely
see true sunlight is a fascinating one
and depending on who you ask
this idea is either utopian or dystopian
now i'm not the biggest fan of sunlight
obviously i live here
but personally i think i'd feel a bit
claustrophobic on trantor
alright guys that was my long-awaited
video on the planet trantor
wow i can't believe i got through that
entire video without that annoying
organism that's been screwing with my
videos showing up anyway guys if you
want to support this channel go to
patreon.com
ideasofaces and spates wait what the
hell that's not my patreon address
you know what i've been noticing a lot
of weird mistakes in my videos
recently like that ridiculous
misspelling of the word incompetent in
my sci-fi is woke video
it's almost like someone's been
intentionally trying to make me look bad
and look at this earlier caption from
this video quinn's a loser don't watch
this channel i didn't write that no you
didn't i did
organism 9186 i knew it was you
idiot all this time i've been hacking
your computer data banks the process is
nearly complete
but why organism why why that is what i
am i am of the trollian empire but it
doesn't have to be like this organism
please silence the process is complete i
have gained access
now we'll be able to begin the deletion
process then no one will ever be able to
watch this shitty channel again organism
no
computer delete
wait why is the data still there why is
your channel still up
oh organism even after all this time you
still have no
idea how the game is played do you think
i didn't know what you were doing this
entire time
you knew about the plan of course i knew
and i gave you a chance organism but you
left me no other choice
what do you mean computer open view
screen
what is it planet trollion
planetrolion897
or should i say what used to be
planet trollion eight nine seven
how could you billions of trillion
people
feminine units masculine units even
fledglings
you monster how could you do this oh but
i didn't
you did when you thought you were
deleting my data
and now you will be my prisoner forever
no i must return home your home is gone
you shouldn't have
moving on that's it for trantor guys
thanks so much for watching guys if you
enjoyed the video make sure you like and
subscribe
and click the paypal link in the
description to support
you